hello critic hmm oh hi bill brain wait
why are you afraid I mean this is
supposed to be our closer review I know
I know just give me a second
but we've been building this up for
years you know how this is supposed to
go your actual afraid not all creepy and
hilarity ensues yes I know I just need
to figure something out
and I spend months writing our comedic
banter I imagine so about why you should
join me well this is more important
right now what is it you know how we're
reviewing a Chuck Norris movie today
calls it force war the only thing where
he literally turns into a bear at the
end of it it's a classic in fact I was
actually thinking maybe you could do
your old joke about shouting you know
that bit that's fun yeah but you see
that's the old me the new me wants to
find new obnoxious memes to be
associated with him
whoa I don't know that's what I've been
trying to figure out what's it been up
to lately
let's see Oh apparently another gay
bashing really yeah he wants key gays
out the boy scouts and he hates same-sex
marriage and he's lashed out against
what he calls Pro gay school propaganda
ah my poor gentle kind of giant how the
wielders turned against you since my
last review wait your fall days she's
just misunderstood everyone's jumping to
conclusions film brain we have got to
cement this image of Chuck Norris that
you and I grew up with but how this is
pretty damning evidence if only the
world knew he just wants people to be as
perfect as he is yeah yes maybe he just
wants everyone to have a little Chuck
Norris in them
wait a minute that's it I don't bring my
beautiful British butter company you'll
just hit the nail on the head oh how he
just wants every man to be like Chuck
Norris right so our new slogan should be
Chuck Norris wants to put himself in
every man
why god that's brilliant I didn't no way
could be miss eternity whenever he walks
around shirtless and sweaty people will
think to themselves Chuck Norris wants
to put himself in every man
whenever each princes being the way the
only associated with leather bars
people will think Chuck Norris was to
put himself in every man whenever he
poses like he's giving him Asajj to a
dummy what surprisingly handsome facial
features people will think Chuck Norris
wants to put himself in every man oh
don't forget about the Boy Scout that's
right Chuck Norris doesn't want the
incredibly dignified image of the Boy
Scouts to be ruined he's the kind of guy
who just wants to help every boy he can
exactly that's why we can say with no
guilt whatsoever Chuck North wants to
put himself in every boy I feel good
about this person not as good as Chuck
Norris doesn't every boy so what do you
say you ready to take a walk is crazy so
versus of course I think we've done well
to restore dignity back to his name well
then let's take a look at four small or
few the third Chuck Norris once put
himself in hardwood I do prefer film
brain I do for her so you Molly
he's gonna love them
this movie was produced to the height of
action stars making movies with
environmental messages well Chuck Norris
and Steven Seagal anyway you want the
khalsa gang directed on deadly ground
where he blew up an oil rig for the
goodly environment yeah you try and
figure that one out
this film however is not directed by
Chuck Norris but rather his younger
brother Aaron the director of the humble
meek classic sidekicks I can just see
how that conversation went hey brother
you did such a good job kissing my ass
in the last film what do you say you do
it again only this time dress me up like
Tiger Lily can I at least get one shot
of you not in slow mode you ever ask me
that again so are you ready to give
yourself to the spirits of the mountain
olia Chuck Norris is putting himself in
it this is forest war we open with a
bunch of 90s haircuts listening to a
story told by the narrator of babe it
was married to an Indian girl she was
waiting for him in their cabin on the
mountain she had a fever and the only
prescription is more cowbell and he'd
ridden his horse to death get back with
medicine for her yes after picking up a
calcium from EPCOT Native American world
seriously his name is jebediah McKenna
but I think jebediah Springfield had
more dignity than him and I get up you
don't seem to be carrying any medicine
either what was the wars a joke medicine
do they have liquid ibuprofen back there
don't worry she's not actually a
character gang of cutthroats hired by
timber agents from the Northern Pacific
we're waiting for him I wanted his trees
for railroad ties but he wouldn't sell
me wouldn't deal was Indian land yes and
as we all know there's no other trees in
the Pacific Northwest well number stable
which is here to use the bathroom he
could sense the danger Minh by then it
was too late he sensed the danger
because it was right next to him how
could he miss that guy it's Chuck Norris
too manly to slightly look down
thankfully he has the Native American
come fight them off with Kanna fought
them in the way of the Indian lunging
and spinning grappling and swirl isn't
that also the way that ballerinas fall
eats and all those poor cutthroats have
are they're useless guns I suppose they
can hit them with their handles or use
them as Spears but I'm sorry they're
completely useless against just fists of
awesomeness
I'm just amazing run a marathon yet
somehow he's still able to stay home six
armed men well it's Chuck Norris for him
fighting six guys is like the water you
drink in the middle of a run but in a
strange twist Chuck Norris ends up dying
in the first five minutes what yeah he
gets axed off pretty early when they
follow me you remember how to use their
guns Oh God
tell me he doesn't spend the rest of the
movie pursuing Demi Moore somehow
winning Whoopi Goldberg and Oscar no
instead of bed drags into third gully
where Forrest magic literally brings him
back to life although in reality this
bear would probably be using his beard
for toilet paper
it does look a naturally absorb it yeah
wolf the Eagle you can become all of
them Indian legend shapeshifter
oh sorry children I accidentally mixed
this up with the story of Manimal but no
writer did you want to hear about a hero
so powerful the only lasted one season
well that's enough fun lamest meeting of
the midnight society ever mister
medicine yeah well what's a shapeshifter
well give you a clue it's in the fucking
word as the ability to take the shape of
those creatures he loved in life never
got to see his wife again that is so sad
then why are you smiling
we see later a town meeting going on
about a lumber company who's looking to
what else cut down the trees it only
brings prosperity and hope for our
future here and again I excuse me mr.
thorn thorn lumber company stands to
benefit a whole lot what about our
alternatives what about the wildlife
what about our Nature Conservancy what
about my cartoons you lost live
injections my harvesting proposal it's
going to change this town around and
that's what we all want isn't it
hey mal I ordered a holdout I'm pretty
sure this is a hootenanny that's Terry
Kaiser from weekend at Bernie's as the
bad guy making it clear there are worse
roles you can get them play a dead guy
throughout the entire film even as bulk
and skull stole sidekicks hard to
believe that boy comes in his punch he's
driven by nothing but greed bring in the
streets when he can or with the dead
town one asshole what do they will do to
him and we're just gonna pick a claim
falling out I guess we just gotta the
town council decide that the one guy can
lock the mountain my dad's a logger -
and he'd never ever write down those old
trees
mr. Madison says those trees are six
eight hundred years old boy these kids
seem bizarrely interested in the
politics of lumber labor what kid would
give a shit about this then Morgan said
about what Pokemon they're going to
trade next unless the woods a suit of
wudu trees I don't think they were care
much honey where've you been I got
delayed
well the kid's father played by Michael
Beck shows up late as apparently he's
been getting drunk all night yeah I'd be
drinking too if I was in San ado need
some sleep
she takes him home since him on the
couch and prays to not God not Buddha
but the mountain to help her in her time
of need great gift of melting snow the
heart that gives life to our forests
he's trying to find a way to save it
sorry kid but I'm a mountain I just kind
of stayed here bus mommy whenever she is
and give her a thought daddy it means in
a while I need your help
so much what do you think should we send
Clarence again emailing for storage
space and time that over reality good
point let's just send one of our dollar
store spirits oh you mean like Chuck
Norris
add to one
so we see the kids are going up for a
hike to the mountain unsupervised
because any kid can handle a fucking
mountain as her mother watches in
confusion about why she has a mushroom
cut now to be fair that is more of a
jellyfish cut I'll name the stupid
nineties haircuts around here this of
course these twelve villains with their
amazingly cartoony musical theme Wow for
a more subtle music when wily coyote is
thinking up a plan of course it doesn't
help the villain is just as cartoony as
the music is nine million board feet of
lumber up there and I want it all like
it sizzle in their own grief I couldn't
care less about the progress of anyone
except Travis thorne boys can we just
cut to the rich-text can go from The
Simpsons whenever he's on screen now
like our kids going on their trip is any
less
time
but how was that Wow I'm tying my shoe
can you believe I'm actually tying my
shoe oh what a wonderful adventure that
was but then suddenly one gets lost from
the groom only to literally be found a
few seconds later what was the point of
that he loses them despite the fact they
were only three steps behind him and
they just locate some a moment later
maybe they were building up he was about
to be gang-raped by you walks or
something some on their playground to
Terabithia they seem to come across
something growling inside just get up
you fucking idiot so the fear with your
legs and low ball but it turns out it
was just a baby bear the whole time
forget that rageh friends that's a good
name boy good thing he wasn't Goverdhan
shit you were thinking it by the way
have you know something kind of
important missing from this Chuck Norris
musaka Laurie Norris he's only gone a
few minutes of screen time I've never
even had a dialogue yet if I want to see
kids play with a bear cub a would have
rented the amazing Pandora venture no
you wonder well I would have been
spirits but it looks like the evil
loggers have located him come on he's
efficient after throwing back that's not
efficient it's worth something no matter
how big it is it worth a lot more if he
was bigger Oh
so these loggers also doubled Brandon
poachers to clearly par the hiring
criteria for this company on a film
brink clearly you should know that when
you hire evil henchmen you need to have
all your bases covered all right if
we're going to hire you on his henchmen
we need to know that you can do more
than just follow evil orders oh we can't
on top of following orders we can also
kill small animals and laughs that
hillbilly yokels make weird faces where
we get kicked in the nuts
I'm still not convinced maybe a little
demonstration oh go ahead guys okay one
final question do you fall for gullible
traps set up by small children oh sure
Bobby's still walking off a burn mark
that was given to him by sangria all
right you're hired
yeah give me five guys sorry Bobby
Thanks so while the bear makes the sound
that Chuck Norris makes when he puts
himself into every man not kidding that
sound out of your head any time soon the
kids stopped the loggers from killing
the bear girl oh wow
but you know better than to run at a man
with a rifle
I should just skin it alive nor Chuck
Norris has anything to say about it
because this movie doesn't have the
budget for shape-shifting we have to be
impressed by shut magical junk cutting
power you go
that's not bad
but you really got it instead of Wow
look at this kid she doesn't know she's
supposed to look blown away or
disturbingly confused neat I guess the
logos runaway is forced Jesus compass
the go by telling her about the bad so
glad you're it's okay your fairy beard
mother is here you were very brave
Austin you saved his life can I be his
friend you are his friend and when he
grows up you'll be his dinner but until
then this is perfectly serviceable how
hold on I got a call
what was that the movie yeah I think
that that is this music is so bland it
actually sounds exactly like my ringtone
listen well this gives a unique set of
phone name I'm not coming back from that
one nor should you
meanwhile our villains continue to tear
down the forest
trees are strong my lord you read them
all
kids up there school's out should have
figured on that that treehouse and I had
to play up there when I was a kid it was
magical
wonderful place
let's get rid of the damn thing whoa
that was almost character development
there oh well back to your dancing of
shooting guns off
speaking of which we see the get along
gang making their oath to them out again
as kids do I asked you to leave it
purush sound we are to it forever bound
we ask you to leave it purush bound we
argue it forever bound we promise to
nobly play in tree houses with friend
Killa birds always wear plaid shirts
always have curly hair cuts hail what's
that stuff Cherisher mountain and all
the earth all its creatures I love how
the shots of the mother is just taken
from the earliest scene of her outside
the petrol station has just been
standing there for hours all right kiddo
I think that's enough playing outside
time to come up in
need a little help there okay they
continue just to do what normal kids do
but made an oath to do so so somehow it
seems more important as they all go
fishing Oh hold on what one second
lemme guess my ringtone near his home
store to be downloaded as an app so
while the children go fishing Chuck
Norris sees a raccoon just in case you
forgot he was Forest Jesus while the
load of SAP explosives to blow the
treehouse up because nothing beats a
good beer potential manslaughter
seriously he sees them playing in the
lake so he assumes they're not gonna be
back there I'll be playing there all day
but it's like a good while before it
finally goes off how is he no fucking
anybody could have gone back there by
that point you won't be able to get away
with this anywhere else um boss are you
sure it's a good idea to blow up a
playground without giving anyone a
little warning oh please
who's gonna be dumb enough to go all the
way up there
uh are we going to do boss you're the
boss now
Bunch
you
while the girl goes to the treehouse to
gut the fish Norris comes across the
loggers don't once again shut them up
I've always thought the more fight
scenes need to be in to cover the
animals randomly watching the action it
seems to say we know we can't be
exciting so that's at least Charlie kids
yeah and isn't me or is this the exact
same fight scene we saw before just put
in front of a truck toss kick slo-mo
North forgetting to have a personality
nothing much of a difference Noah's
looks into his eyes and figures out the
explosives are about to go off
you know for an omnipotent spirit of the
forest don't you think it would have
noticed a little hiccup like that Oh
what the hell
and to yam is odorous in the chorus why
does he even need to turn into an animal
when we already established he can
teleport anywhere at any time at well
he's only gone 15 seconds
okay very long 15 seconds but still the
treehouse blows up and everyone thinks
the girl is a goner
which she kind of is but Norris is there
to once again bring her back through the
exact same effects again that I think
the original you stole from ghostbusters
in the first place how are you feeling
Osteen was i sleeping yes you're
sleeping huh you might also be able to
turn into a cockroach now just don't be
alarmed
is this your home forest have you lived
here long long time hello long time
writing taking meager sleep once the
girl's father finds out he rushes
through the treehouse thinking that he's
too late Jesus Christ guy it's a fucking
Chuck Norris movie not a Sally Field
flick I know
ride the dog and feed the kitty gave
more subtle performance so it looks like
the kid is okay as everybody tries to
figure out what's going on with that
forest it's not haunted I know that
enchanted maybe no I'm sure many
hauntings look nicer if you just call
the enchanted poltergeist is a family
movie if you just use different
terminology
whimsically delightful one more bad news
seems to be in the horizon the ones on
the moon he managed to get a temporary
permit he can start cutting the trees at
noon tomorrow temporary permit what is
this the purge you can suddenly perform
illegal activity as long as you have a
note EPA anyone so thorn is on his way
to chop down the forest
don't forget your bad boy kids and
seeing how this is a 90s kidz film we of
course have to rip off the home alone
ending with traps set up all over the
place
help you can tell The Wizard of Oz in
the 90s and you would still have to have
a home alone ended you just attached the
bucket of water to a string or something
however we're home alone was quick and
well paced this is nerve-racking ly slow
as molasses I think somebody's trying to
pull my chain Oh will you get thumbtacks
in the log there mr. thorn it's the
green wienies wienies environmentalists
they're out there continue mr. Williams
fine you can take care of your boo-boo
when we get back with ease so long does
this go on for it's a Chuck Norris movie
and yet all the Chuck Norris scenes have
been replaced for kids Fidel Castro and
Peter Parker's landlord you gutless
environmental punks Travis well with all
those bales just kill the bastard I'm
sure I never can survive being tied to a
log roll down a cliff and tossed into a
six-story drop go Murder Squad and the
kids distract the rest of the loggers by
playing that awesome makes falling one
cassette
bonus points the guy who air guitars
with a chainsaw this is the stupid and
magical in there and drive to stop but
you're gonna cut down for it we can't
let him do that
what are we getting now we've got to
stop them Oh brilliant strategy thanks
Patton well yeah looks like I got a
break my killing kids rule which we
never had I'll let you have a free shot
huh come on here give me one right here
come on come on right there well if I
loads anything from Tom and Jerry
cartoons this never backfires whoa I so
did not set myself up for that Europe
Chuck Norris is back again and having so
rarely I have to keep note of it
you wouldn't be so hot without your
slow-mo
that's right Internet
I just stopped a chainsaw with my bare
hands I'm just trying to make these
memes easier for you
gee film brain what do you think he's
gonna do to him this time oh I don't
know about the same thing he's done
every single time
oh you me big him up and Fossum Jesus
working on his fighting the school of
hot potato of course the police arrived
to arrest them but form runs away and
asked Norris for help because yeah sure
he looks like someone who'd be on his
side I got to get over this mouth over
here alright I give you 10,000 bucks if
he can help me out cuz I got guys
chasing me why are they chasing you
because I want to cut down a few trees
okay oh gee when you put it like that
makes the plot sound pretty ridiculous
look at that he used the magic of the
mountain to throw towards a tree stop at
the tree help out himself and then land
face up even though we thought face down
for Jesus works in mysterious ways
holy magic I believe in he's a magic of
the almighty dollar well I think that
goes without saying you said yes to a
Chuck Norris movie the only dreams you
believe in are the ones that you can buy
let's the only kind there are oh there's
nothing I can do to change your mind
then maybe RK and there it is the early
hand of Meister 1 on screen morph and it
is glorious I don't even know what to
say here it's one of the most famous
chuck norris moments ever he right in
front of our eyes turns into a bear The
Thorn is so awestruck he appears to be
moving oh look at her
he's making so many weird sounds he
could be a serial mascot one bite of goo
fields will make you go sir please find
a rest thorn the girl's father has made
deputy again because he proved it to be
sober for a couple of hours and they
rebuilt the tree house with prosciutto
lumber yeah wait a minute man the high
five anything yeah
water high five bro thank you mountain
we hang this eco-friendly Denny's
placemat in your honor
but then the girl you know the one who
was snickering at the death of Norris's
wife looks up and see the two of them
together wait a minute if she was with
him the whole time how come she did help
out well remember film brain Chuck
Norris wants to put himself in every man
getting a woman involved would just be
an abomination against God well I guess
I see your point
really
here's to having a Native American movie
with only 1/8 of American shown for 2
seconds and not given any lines of
dialogue yeah that was forest warrior
and to say the least this is a baffling
yard movie 4 stars is a Chuck Norris
movie where he shows up for maybe all
about 10 minutes of bears how I think
Stephen Scott appeared more inside his
directing video movies it mostly seems
to just be copying the most popular
trans detailing like protecting the
environment and home alone and slapping
together into one cheesy mess
I mean who exact this is aimed at kids
who rely Walker Texas Ranger does anyone
want to see Chuck Norris stroking his
ego by playing the benevolent god the
forest who is also really good kicking
people in the face it does plays like a
country music version of Captain Planet
especially since it's so cartoonish and
over-the-top you'll probably laugh
yourself into a hernia well before the
majesty of Chuck Norris becoming a bear
it's pretty stupid and drenched in 90s
cheese but as do the kids films go yeah
it's pretty standard a stupid look like
film being said the few scenes that are
so bizarre and trippin with Chuck Norris
it's eagle are far too funny to overlook
so if you want to know about the spirit
of the mountain as say told by Chuck
Norris's karate commandos then this is
the good one to check out
well film break it's nice after all
these years we finally got a chance to
do a crossover together
indeed Chris egg but you Tommy does feel
bad about what we said about Chuck
Norris earlier yeah maybe we haven't
done enough to restore his image like we
thought maybe we could give him a theme
song yeah something that kids can relate
to but can also teach a good lesson as
well got any thoughts
well one don't you put it in your mouth
don't you find it in your mouth film rim
I love and I do mean it
I'm a nostalgia critic and remember
don't you put it in your mouth don't you
find it in your mouth don't you stop it
in your bag I'm stopping in your face
you